c'est l'heure de notre second débat et
je vous propose un gros plan sur la
personnalité et le bilan du ministre de
la Justice Éric Dupont-Moretti son
projet de loi destiné je le cite à
tourner la page de la clochardisation de
la justice est examinée en ce moment au
Sénat on en parlera dans une minute avec
nos invités mais d'abord le portrait
d'un avocat devenu garde des sceaux avec
Cécile si
Istres de la justice ou l'accepteriez
devenir ministre jamais en 2018 Eric
Dupont-Moretti était sûr de lui non mais
personne n'aurait jamais l'idée saute
totalement saugrenu incongru un vrai
semblable de me proposer cela et
pourtant si Emmanuel Macron lui a
proposé il a dit oui
Eric Dupond-Moretti l'avocat pénaliste
la bête noire des prétoirs que l'on
surnomme aussi l'akitator a finalement
troqué sa robe en 2020 pour la Bible
politique je ne fais de guerre à
personne je veux avec vous
garder le meilleur
échanger le pire un costume de ministre
de la justice qu'il a du mal à endosser
dès le début il est accusé par des
magistrats d'utiliser sa nouvelle
fonction pour régler des comptes
personnels il est renvoyé devant la Cour
de Justice de la République une première
pour un garde des sous en exercice en
tant que justiciable j'ai comme tout le
monde des avocats qui feront valoir mes
droits et en tant que ministre je suis à
100% dans la tâche qui est la mienne un
ministre à 100% mais pas du sérail
politique
Eric Dupont-Moretti ne maîtrise pas
forcément les codes cette adepte de
l'ajout d'oratoire n'hésite pas à aller
au conflit voir utiliser la violence
verbale et va parfois trop loin comme ce
jour où il a fait un bras d'honneur dans
l'hémicycle au président du groupe LR je
suis je le dis à toutes les
représentations nationales
profondément affectée
par ce moment que je suis
amené à vivre je n'ai pas voulu viser le
président Marleix mais si mon geste a
été mal interprété je lui présente mes
excuses ainsi qu'à toutes leurs
présentations nationales le style
Dupont-Moretti peut déplaire ou séduire
la sénatrice Marie merci apprécie ce
ministre peu commun depuis ses premiers
pas au Sénat
j'ai été frappé par son attitude quand
il est arrivé on a eu vraiment
l'impression qu'il arrivait dans un
monde qui ne connaissait pas vraiment et
il était tout à fait j'ai presque envie
de dire presque tout champ parce qu'il
écoutait beaucoup il écoutait il nous
transperçait des yeux aussi mais on
sentait qu'il avait vraiment envie
d'apprendre notre fonctionnement après
trois ans il se défend d'être celui qui
a augmenté les budgets de la justice et
réformés le système judiciaire jugé trop
lent et opaque par les Français
voilà la personnalité le bilan d'Éric
Dupont au Moretti au menu de ce débat de
sens public avec Sophie Coignières
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
au Point hauteur de ce livre la tyrannie
de la médiocrité publiée aux éditions de
l'Observatoire j'accueille également
Stéphane lerudulier bonsoir c'est la
peur LR des Bouches-du-Rhône et membre
de la commission des lois face à vos
Erwan Malan bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi député madame du Finistère et
vice-président la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée Mathieu croissanto est resté
à mes côtés évidemment Sophie si vous
deviez choisir un mot une expression
pour pour définir Éric Dupont-Moretti
vous dire il y a quoi
son métier depuis toujours c'est son
métier d'avocat la question c'est de
savoir si effectivement c'est avocat
ultra médiatique et souvent extrêmement
efficace il a obtenu beaucoup de
victoires dans les prétoirs
a vraiment abandonné sa robe ou s'il y a
une sorte de robe transparente qui reste
un peu collé à lui
est-ce qu'il a quitté sa robe d'avocat
en devenant ministre c'est une vraie
question en tout cas il a eu du mal sans
doute à s'adapter à ces nouvelles
fonctions qu'on s'était stablement mais
reconnaissons quand même une
personnalité
hors norme un ténor du barreau qui est
plus à démontrer vu les affaires qu'il a
dû qu'il a dû plaider et je pense qu'au
fur et à mesure il s'est quand même la
fonction je le dis
de manière avec le recul ça fait trois
ans maintenant et ce texte qui est en
discussion scénale le prouve je l'ai
trouvé beaucoup plus mesuré beaucoup
plus de recul que il y a 2 ans le
contenu et lui dans la forme dans la
façon surtout dans la forme dans la
façon de le défendre sur le fond puisque
ça c'est des c'est idé contre idée mais
c'est surtout dans la forme on avait
l'impression lorsqu'il était en
discussion générale lorsqu'il défendait
un texte qu'il était en plaidoirie il y
a deux ans ou trois ans c'était assez
flagrant avec tous les excès ou les
joues de verbales voire même des fois
des gestuelles qui étaient vraiment
incompatibles avec la fonction de
ministre dans en plus au sein d'une
assemblée est-ce que ce passé d'avocats
brillant empêche Eric Dupont-Moretti
d'être un ministre impartial notamment
avec les magistrats
non je pense pas vous savez je suis
rapporteur du corps rapporteur à
l'assemblée du texte dont on parlait
qu'un grand texte de réforme de la
justice on en parlera de moyens
supplémentaires forts et je suis frappé
parce que on est en audition en ce
moment on voit beaucoup de gens je vois
beaucoup de d'acteurs du monde de la
justice parfois certains de ces
opposants ça peut arriver et tous
souligne une chose c'est sa
détermination à changer la justice dans
notre pays à lui donner des moyens et à
faire en sorte qu'elle marche et je
crois que c'est c'est ce qu'on lui
demande et vous voyez par exemple
récemment il y a une tribune de
Jean-Jacques urvoise Jean-Jacques
urvoise ancien garde des sceaux et qui
soulignait qui soulignait l'importance
de ce qu'il était en train de mettre en
place des magistrats spécifiques les
magistrats c'est sûr que ça coince un
peu quand vous avez été un grand avocat
vous avez peut-être fait perdre parfois
des avocats des magistrats donc
peut-être il y a un peu de de
d'amertume pour certains mais je crois
je crois que c'est passé il y a eu un
moment très dur mais aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il reconnaissent tous en tout
cas peut-être ceux qui sont moins
syndicalisés peut-être ils reconnaissent
tous sa détermination et son action qui
est plutôt bonne voire très bonne au
ministère de la Justice depuis 3 ans
maintenant alors je tiens à deux
promesses on fera on reviendra sur la la
réforme la loi de programmation de la
justice on en parlera et évidemment on
reviendra sur les questions de budget et
de et de bilan du ministre là on reste
un peu sur ça personnalité et sur ce qui
le fragilise c'est quand même cette mise
en examen pour prise illégal d'intérêt
on voit en procès dans la cour de
justice de la République la décision
annonçait le 3 octobre dernier deux
jours après la sénatrice socialiste de
Paris Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie
interpellé le gouvernement en séance
le 3 mars 2017 Emmanuel Macron affirmait
publiquement un principe tout ministre
mis en examen devra quitter le
gouvernement
engagement qui fut repris par Edouard
Philippe Premier ministre et qui fut
appliqué François berousse en rappel
quelques jours après la prise de
fonction de celui-ci comme garde des
sceaux
quelques années plus tard il y a deux
jours nous apprenons que le garde des
sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti ici présent
et renvoyé devant la Cour de Justice de
la République pour des faits commis
pendant l'exercice de ce mandat actuel
comme ministre de la Justice et rien
simplement la réaffirmation de la
confiance que vous lui donnez
erwanon pourquoi la jurisprudence Bayrou
on pourrait remonter plus loin en
parlant de la jurisprudence baladure ne
sait pas appliquer à Éric Dupond-Moretti
c'est
une situation et un dossier très
particulier quand même il faut quand
même rappeler qu'au départ il est
victime le garde des sceaux dans cette
histoire en tant qu'avocat et et
il lance une procédure d'enquête qui est
d'enquête administrative qui est fait
très vite après être appelé en poste
qui était lancée par
sa
Nicole Belloubet donc il avait pas
beaucoup d'autres solutions et c'était
une enquête administrative donc
aujourd'hui
je pense que le dossier n'est pas du
tout le même que pour d'autres que
d'autres situations donc le enfin pour
les oppositions je vois bien une
opposition ça s'oppose surtout surtout
maintenant mais là je le
je pense qu'elle connaît la procédure je
trouve qu'il y a un peu mauvaise foi bon
voilà Sophie cogner votre avis sur sur
ce dossier sur ce que dit Marie-Pierre
delagrantie c'est un ministre en
exercice renvoyé dans la cour de justice
de la République enfin voilà on est on
est dans une situation complexe
intenable je sais pas quel adjectif
employer comment vous l'analysez je
retiendrai tout vous adjectifs
mais c'est l'histoire d'une situation
intenable annoncée évolue parce que
quand
Eric Dupond-Moretti est confirmé dans
ses fonctions de garde des sceaux après
l'élection présidentielle
après la nomination de Madame borne à
Matignon en gros il fait assez peu doute
qu'avec du pot Moretti dans les semaines
ou les mois à venir va être mis en
examen tout le monde le sait donc la
question pour le président de la
République c'est de savoir si oui ou non
il garde
ce ministre de la Justice or il décide
de le garder donc effectivement moi
c'est pour ça que je trouve que
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie là je parle
pas du fond du dossier je parle vraiment
bah non je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je pense que un affichage
politique c'est-à-dire que à partir du
moment où vous énoncez des principes et
des principes qui ont été énoncés par
cette majorité et par ce gouvernement au
début du premier quinquennat de manière
extrêmement forte je vous rappelle que
la première loi votée était la loi sur
la confiance dans la vie publique et
politique donc c'est enfin il y a eu une
sorte de d'affirmation très forte
et bien je trouve que ça fait ça fait ça
fait des ordres sur le message politique
envoyé votre avis sans doute que il
aurait fallu maintenir cette
jurisprudence maintenant la question de
fond c'est est-ce que ça l'empêche dans
l'exercice de sa fonction en qualité de
ministre et là je serai beaucoup plus
nuancé on voit très bien que il propose
des textes qui ce qui ont forcément des
avantages des inconvénients dans des
battra tout à l'heure mais il a été
diminué un certain moment et je pense
que là la tempête passée tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et il y a le conflit
intérieur il est jamais très loin j'ai
juste expliqué alors ça peut sembler
assez complexe mais finalement ça ne
l'est pas trop le procureur général près
la Cour de cassation François molency
part à la retraite c'est Éric
Dupond-Moretti qui devait nommer son
successeur sauf que celui qui
représentera l'accusation à la Cour de
Justice de la République c'est justement
celui qui va succéder à François
Malaison qu'on se retrouve avec avec un
Eric Dupond-Moretti qui aurait nommé
celui chargé de l'accusé enfin vous
voyez c'était c'était totalement Ubu
est-ce que donc ça a été déporté ce sera
ce sera décidé à Matignon oui mais on
est bien quand même dans la
démonstration que ça l'empêche de faire
son travail de ministre normalement oui
mais après c'est après après c'est le
rôle de la Cour de Justice de la
République la formation de jugement
enfin on est en train d'y réfléchir au
Sénat notamment sur sur la réforme des
institutions est-ce qu'il faut intégrer
la partie civile dans dans le procès
enfin toutes ces questions sont en
suspens et c'est une situation inédite
mais si on regarde par rapport à sa
fonction l'exercice de sa fonction je ne
pense pas qu'il était empêché par par
ses affaires là mais voilà bon après je
parle en tant que législateur au niveau
de l'exécutif moi l'affichage politique
n'est pas le bon effectivement là je
rejoins je rejoins ce que disait madame
mais
sur le le concret de ces actions de
terrain ou de ces propositions de textes
rien n'empêche aujourd'hui de faire son
son travail et ses missions correctement
il se pourront en cassation si je me
trompe donc on a pas de date pour
l'instant de d'audience devant la Cour
de Justice de la République voilà la
procédure je suis son cours mais ce
serait quand même une première
et c'est pas bon pour l'Institut du
sujet enfin j'ai l'impression de
d'enfoncer les portes ouvertes tout le
monde me dit non mais quand même oui non
mais je comprends les mois qui peut y
avoir mais je il faut il faut que que
les gens qui sont un peu curieux de
cette situation à y voir ce qu'est le
dossier et ce qui est cette histoire qui
est quand même un peu c'est pas c'est
pas comme s'il avait piqué dans la
caisse quoi vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est une histoire de procédure de
procédure qui qui a commencé quand il
était avocat et quand il était donc bon
c'est vraiment une procédure assez
particulière alors moi je comprends je
comprends sur le symbole sur voilà mais
comme on a justement fait cette loi
aujourd'hui on a des on a on est on a
des obligations de transparence qui sont
qui sont inédites etc je moi je suis pas
plus inquiet que ça sur ce sujet et je
constate comme mon collègue sénateur que
il fait le job et il le fait même plutôt
très bien Mathieu avis je pense qu'il il
paye une erreur politique je ne peux pas
me prononcer sur le fond de la faire du
point de vue judiciaire mais il paye une
erreur politique du pont Moretti c'est
de ne pas être déporté dès son arrivée
dès son arrivée
de tous les dossiers quand il a eu à
connaître et la question
et cette décision a été prise à
l'automne 2020 et ces gens Castex qui a
récupéré les choses à Matignon mais s'il
s'était déporté dès le début on lui a
conseillé d'être on lui a dit qu'il
était pas obligé de le faire et je vais
et si je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
je vous laisse regarder parce que j'ai
pas envie politique après est-ce que
c'est une faute
[Musique]
parce qu'on lui on
c'est une déclaration de guerre
règlement de compte des syndicats de
magistrats
il y a une partie des années de
magistrats qui voulait se le payer vous
savez c'est c'est ça me fait penser à
Claude Allègre dans une autre sauf que
Éric Dupont-Moretti serait pour
l'instant et toute proportion gardée un
Claude qui a réussi c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont arrivés tous les deux du milieu
sans en être en voulant secouer le
mammouth pour dégraisser l'expression
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
donc c'était des décors des corps jugés
étrangers et et et trop trop violent
avec leur administration et il y en a un
qui ça n'a rien donné pas eu de grandes
réformes d'éducation nationale et là
Eric Dupont-Moretti c'est un peu le
chemin à l'inverse qui est pris parce
que si on regarde le bilan législatif en
tout cas il y a des choses à son actif
on va revoir quand même l'image parce
que bon on pose la question de d'un
ministre sous pression parler de voilà
d'une affaire qui peut-être le fragilise
et plus généralement est-ce que ça
fagisse l'institution voilà ce 7 mars
dernier c'était il y a trois mois jour
pour jour quand Olivier Marleix fait
allusion à cette mise en examen dont on
parle il y a ce bras d'honneur double
bras d'honneur alors il s'excusera
ensuite il se justifiera en disant c'est
à ma propre présence d'innocence que je
faisais un bras d'honneur bon on peut
trouver ça allez hop finalement oui
alors la justification
oui c'est pas sa meilleure défense c'est
ce que vous lui dit de la part d'un
avocat mais je repose la question un peu
plus sérieuse qu'on peut en rire on se
dit bon après tout pourquoi pas ça peut
arriver même à l'Assemblée mais bon
quand même
l'institution judiciaire qui défend
qu'il se fragilise forcément avec une
image comme cela et on peut comprendre
humainement la difficulté de résister à
cette pression voilà il y a les deux
lectures absolument et ben je me
souviens de cette de cette séance à
l'Assemblée nationale et et il y a eu
entre votre reportage était très bien
fait mais effectivement le temps lui
manquait pour donner toutes les étapes
intermédiaires qu'il y a eu jusqu'au
moment où le Garde des Sceaux a
condescendu avec cette espèce de langage
chantourner et contourner
des excuses qui n'en étaient pas sur
quelque chose que même un enfant de 5
ans aurait qualifiénement sont bon donc
il a il a vraiment fallu lui mettre le
couteau sous la gorge le bazooka dans le
dos etc pour qu'il accepte de de ce
enfin j'étais là mais oui je vois je
vois le je vois il sait pas excusé tout
de suite on peut en convenir comme ça a
été très rapide il y a eu il y a eu il y
a une très longue très longue
intervention
légitime parce qu'effectivement et moi
je dis parce que d'après ce que j'ai
entendu de plusieurs sources parce qu'il
était pas extrêmement chaud pour
s'excuser ah je suis pas d'accord avec
ça parce que moi je l'ai vu juste après
je je
lui ai dit voilà il m'a dit oui mais je
vais m'excuser tout de suite et c'était
5 minutes après j'étais là et il y a eu
du temps parce que parce que il y a eu
du temps parce que c'était la durée de
c'est pas lui qui gère la durée de
l'interruption de séance
un petit peu ça tout de même sans
vouloir le le défendre sur ce sur ce cas
là parce que ce geste là ce geste là je
pense évidemment qu'il n'aurait
certainement pas dû le faire et encore
moins dans l'hémicycle face à un
parlementaire mais les propos de du
président Marley que ça ce moment-là
président du groupe président du groupe
LR sont très durs et surtout on n'était
pas sur ce sujet c'était pas le sujet et
ils sont très durs tout à fait vrai et
donc et donc voilà mais je ne l'excuse
pas du tout
savoir tenir ses nerfs un parlementaire
doit savoir garder ses nerfs est-ce
qu'il a réagi en avocat à ce moment-là
Stéphane Aurélie je pense même pas que
donc de ne pas accepter la critique ou
de pas accepter le le position vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais c'est ce
que je veux pas dans le bras d'honneur
il a eu du mal à prendre la bille d'un
ministre il n'est pas du sérail il fait
pas partie du monde politique donc
forcément c'est quelqu'un d'assez
sanguin sur le côté
on sait qu'il aime les affrontements et
malheureusement là les nerfs ont lâché
et ce geste est totalement déplorable
certes pour autant sincèrement est-ce
que sur le fond sur ce qu'il apporte on
peut être pour encore une fois on peut
être contre mais moi j'ai quand même
l'impression ça n'engage que moi qui
essaye de faire au mieux au mieux son
boulot malgré le fait avancer son
ministère voilà ça je pense rapide j'ai
la chance d'être dans la mandature
précédente tout près du banc des
ministres sur une question QAG sa
première Q âgée première Q âgée
catastrophique parce que question
gouvernement
de parlementaires question au
gouvernement évidemment débroua
l'interrompt lui pas habitué il commence
à interpeller à faire son son discours
avec les gens qui l'interpellent sauf
qu'une QG était deux minutes et pas deux
minutes 10 secondes donc il se fait
couper bon moi je suis à côté lui je lui
dis monsieur le garde des sceaux la
prochaine fois allez-y foncez la
deuxième la deuxième qui a joué il avait
compris et la deuxième QAG il l'a tracé
et c'est très bien passé on l'a évoqué
Sophie cogner en parler tout à l'heure
les raisons pour lesquelles Emmanuel
Macron a gardé son garde des sauts en
poste Mathieu ça vaut le coup de
regarder un peu plus près quels sont les
relations entre
Eric Dupond-Moretti et le président de
la République qui est devenu un coup
politique parce qu'elle était 2020 quand
il est nommé place Vendôme au ministère
de Justice Eric Dupont-Moretti c'est un
peu la surprise du chef le seul nouveau
nom connu du grand public dans un
nouveau gouvernement qui ne donne pas
dans les paillettes à l'image de du
premier ministre Jean Castex que
personne ne connaissait donc Éric
Dupond-Moretti c'est la fois une gueule
une voix un style alors Emmanuel Macron
Eric duponty n'était pourtant pas des
très très proches la légende raconte que
c'est Brigitte Macron qui l'a repéré
comme s'il fallait repérer
Dupont-Moretti un soir de 2019 où est
l'assistait au théâtre à une pièce que
jouer l'ogre des prétois avec guichet
fermé alors pourtant Eric Dupont-Moretti
c'était juré de ne jamais on l'a revu
accepter d'être ministre son seul
engagement politique en fait c'était
vaguement un comité de soutien à Martine
Aubry à Lille pour pour les municipales
il faut croire que donc le président de
la République a suspentré persuasif Eric
Dupont depuis n'a jamais regretté ça
c'est intéressant effectivement et c'est
devenu et encore aujourd'hui un polyurde
ou un poids lourd du gouvernement oui
c'est d'ailleurs un des rares ministres
à avoir été laissé à son poste en juin
dernier à l'image d'un Gérald Darmanin
place Beauvau ou d'un Bruno Le Maire à
Bercy et sur l'échiquier gouvernemental
Eric Dupond-Moretti a su jouer les
contrepoids avec le premier c'est à dire
Gérald Darmanin dans une répartition des
rôles très bien orchestrées il faut le
dire très bien communiquer entre la
justice et la police voilà et puis il a
pu aussi pu compter sur le second pour
desserrer chaque année les cordons de la
bourse un peu sur ordre de l'idée mais
en lui octroyant Bruno Le Maire lui
octroyé des budgets historiques à lire
jamais la justice a connu autant
d'augmentation budgétaire mais surtout
lui qu'on disait un peu tonitruant pied
dans le plat peu accoutumé au mœurs
politiques et puis parfois
ours mal léché mais il s'est révélé plus
fin politique que beaucoup ne le
croyaient en faisant adopter des projets
de loi plutôt sans tambour ni trompette
Emmanuel Macron qui juge ses ministres à
la façon dont il lance et ils exécutent
leur politique avec une expression
est-ce que ça sort droit devant souvent
le président de la République et ben il
a vite été sur ce point rassuré parce
qu'avec Eric Dupont-Moretti pour le coup
ça sort droit et c'est voté je parle en
termes de bilan législatif et donc un
prix dans la République qui l'a toujours
soutenu malgré ses affaires judiciaires
oui soutient son fail du gardien au
garde des sceaux on en a parlé quitte à
renier les promesses de la République
exemplaire comme disait tout à l'heure
dans l'extrait qu'on a vu Marie-Pierre
de la Gontrie et enterrer la
jurisprudence de la dure c'est vrai que
François Bayrou qui occupait le même
poste n'avait pas eu droit à cette
mensuétude présidentielle loin de là on
s'en souvient ont lieu en fait on estime
sur le fond qu'il s'agit d'une affaire
j'ouvre les guillemets de corne cul et
sur la forme que lâcher Eric
Dupont-Moretti reviendrait à céder à des
syndicats de magistrats qui se sont
jurés d'avoir la peau de leur ministre
comme dirait l'autre qui viennent le
chercher qui deviennent le chercher
Sophie Coignard vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer tout à l'heure mais c'est
peut-être aussi en creux un constat de
faiblesse du gouvernement c'est-à-dire
si Emmanuel Macron est obligé de garder
Eric Dupond-Moretti c'est qu'il y a pas
tant de poids lourd quoi c'est un petit
peu ce que disait Mathieu croissanto
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement quand
le la seule comment dirais
annonce spectaculaire du du gouvernement
borne c'était Papen Diaz souvenez-vous à
c'était la seule prise que vous pouvez
un peu
mettre au crédit du président de la
première ministre et donc effectivement
garder du garder Éric Dupont-Moretti ça
avait au moins de vertus et peut-être un
peu plus la première c'est de garder
quelqu'un qui est comment dirais une
notoriété absolument considérable dans
un gouvernement qu'on qualifie souvent
de gouvernement de fantômes quand on
veut être un peu méchant et la deuxième
chose et bien c'est effectivement et ça
a été très bien dit c'est que Emmanuel
Macron déteste cédé à la pression donc
l'idée que que
Dupond-Moretti doivent partir aurait été
vécu par le Président de la République
comme une sorte de renoncement personnel
assez peu jupiterienne mais alors c'est
intéressant parce que le prénom
République ne lui tient pas non plus
rigueur d'un échec électoral quand même
il faut se souvenir qu'avec
Dupont-Moretti il a fait une campagne
pour les révolutionner les régionales
dans dans le nord c'était 2021
Erwan il y a d'autres ministres qui
auraient pas survécu à tout ça quoi une
campagne ratée une des affaires
judiciaires enfin en campagne je sais
pas une perdue voilà c'est perdu chose
tout à fait campagne perdu dans un le
contexte extrêmement difficile une
région c'était une terre de conquête
pour le coup donc c'était pas simple
donc sans doute aussi pour ça qu'il lui
en a pas tenu rigueur mais moi moi c'est
pas ça qu'il faut regarder c'est surtout
les résultats je pense que le Président
de la République qui est quelqu'un de
d'assez pragmatique il voit que la
justice est en train de se réformer on a
on a passé des textes ça a été dit avec
avec succès des textes importants et là
on va arriver dans une séquence de de
refondation de rénovation forte de la
justice avec des moyens conséquents donc
je pense que de la stabilité pour pour
cette belle institution avec un garde
des sceaux qui qui dure un peu je pense
que c'est bien aussi
du point de vue politique il était aussi
conçu Éric Dupont-Moretti quand même
missile anti-temps et c'est plus que les
résultats électoraux parce que c'est des
régionales qui vont avec étaient quand
même très très flamboyante pour la
majorité on s'en souvient 0 pointé mais
en tout cas c'est il avait une mission
qui était d'être un missile anti-antoin
national et de ce point de vue c'est
vrai que le bilan quand on voit les
scores du rassemblement national mitigé
il est pas le seul responsable mais
d'ailleurs une quelque chose qui est
tout à fait intrigant dans dans
la manière dont le garde des sceaux
entend combattre le front le Front
national enfin le rassemblement c'est
que il a fait exactement sur une chaîne
du service public je crois ce week-end
ce que le président de la République a
reproché à sa première ministre quelques
jours plus tôt c'est-à-dire que chercher
de vieux arguments si vous aviez
question posée si vous aviez à poser une
question à Marine Le Pen que lui demande
auriez-vous et là il répond êtes-vous
Pétain ou Poutine êtes-vous Pétain ou
Poutine c'est enfin c'est assez proche
de ce que de en fait de disons de la
tonalité de la texture de la de ce que
Elisabeth borne avait dit sur donc
l'héritage pétainiste du Front National
et du rassemblement national et qui
n'avait pas été fortement apprécié par
le Président de la République considère
qu'aujourd'hui on peut ne peut plus
lutter
contre l'extrême droite avec avec des
mots et des arguments qu'il qualifient
dater enfin des années 90 votre avis sur
le poids politique de d'un Éric
Dupond-Moretti Stéphane Audier cette
campagne ratée ou perdue je sais pas
quel terme employé quel bilan vous en
faites vous non j'ai régional c'est un
poids lourd un poids lourd du
gouvernement premièrement deuxièmement
c'est un fin connaisseur quand même de
l'institution judiciaire et pour
réformer la justice il vaut mieux avoir
à sa tête quelqu'un qui a déjà
appréhendé sur le terrain les
difficultés ou les problématiques
maintenant sur est-ce que véritablement
c'est un homme politique je dirais pour
leur pas du tout mais à la rigueur il ne
le revendique pas lui ce qu'il veut
c'est un gouvernement de mission c'est
sa mission c'est la réforme de
l'institution judiciaire je suis pas
certain et pourquoi ils ont régional à
ce moment donc c'était demandé par sans
doute le président de la République ou
l'exécutif je n'en sais rien mais en
tout état de cause on voit que sa
volonté n'est pas d'aller de campagne en
campagne prendre une députation ou alors
s'enraciner dans un territoire pour être
pour devenir
législatifs
sont son combat viscéral contre les
idées du rassemblement national et
contre le rassemblement national qui
l'ont qui l'ont amené à aller dans cette
dans cette conquête électorale parce que
parce que ce qu'on peut lui reconnaître
aussi enfin moi j'ai partage ça avec lui
c'est son combat contre les idées du
rassemblement national et toutes ces
idées qui quelque part aussi
affaiblissent l'État de droit et ça
c'est c'est une détermination puissante
qu'il a et qu'on peut pas lui enlever il
est quand même amoureux de de son
département du Nord aussi voilà on peut
aller on va on peut-être vous avez vu
que la question de la société civile si
nous reste un peu de temps en fin de
débat on y reviendra parce que c'est
aussi un des un des éléments que je
trouve intéressant à à creuser quand on
parle du bilan de d'Éric Dupond-Moretti
mais on en vient à ce projet de loi donc
on l'a dit les uns les autres et
lui-même évidemment le répète à son
crédit un budget en hausse constante on
écoute le garde des sociétés au mois de
septembre dernier ministère va
bénéficier pour la troisième année
consécutive à nouveau de plus 8% en 2023
on peut parler d'un triplet historique
je ne gueule pas ce mot il suffit
d'avoir un peu de mémoire
et de regarder quelles ont été les
budgets du ministère de la Justice
j'ai presque envie de vous dire depuis
le début de la 5e République
ce sont 710 millions
supplémentaires qui viendront abonder en
2023 le service public de la justice
le budget s'élèvera à 9,6 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2023 voilà budget
en hausse dans ce projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation de la
justice 2023 2027 Mathias AES va nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Mathias que peut-on dire de ce
budget de cette loi et bien c'est un
c'est une réforme qui se veut ambitieuse
comme l'a fait comprendre le garde des
sceaux alors cela commence donc par plus
de moyens vous l'avez entendu les
crédits de la justice devraient donc
atteindre 11 milliards d'euros d'ici la
fin du quinquennat alors cet argent sera
alloué à différents postes de dépenses
tout d'abord la création de 10000 postes
supplémentaires au sein du ministère
parmi lesquels 1500 magistrats et 1500
greffiers ici au Sénat un amendement a
même été adopté ce mercredi pour porter
à 1800 le nombre de recrutement de
greffiers alors les crédits seront aussi
utilisés pour revaloriser les métiers de
la justice et pour enclencher une vraie
transition numérique qui devra aboutir à
ce que le ministre appelle le zéro
papier à horizon 2027 là aussi mais pour
la rapporteur du texte ici au Palais du
Luxembourg Agnès canaye une augmentation
des moyens ne suffira pas tes moyens
supplémentaires ne suffiront pas à
atteindre l'objectif recherché sans une
réforme en profondeur de l'organisation
du travail des magistrats et sans une
véritable simplification des procédures
applicables
mes chers collègues la réorganisation
passe par une révision importante du
corps judiciaire corollaire des
recrutements attendus est-ce qu'on peut
dire malgré tout que ce texte fait
consensus notamment sur la partie budget
oui hier sur la seule première journée
d'examen du texte les sénateurs ont voté
quelques-uns des premiers articles du
projet de loi la hausse des moyens
budgétaires demandés par le gouvernement
c'est fait l'habilitation donner à
l'exécutif pour réformer le code du
procès de procédure pénale même chose
une réécriture de la procédure pénale
qui se fera dans les deux ans par voie
d'ordonnance l'idée étant de simplifier
la procédure et par la même d'accélérer
les délais de la justice il a aussi été
question des violences contre les femmes
hier oui pas moins de 7 femmes ont été
tuées au mois de mai par leur conjoint
ou ex-conjoint 48 depuis le début de
l'année alors pour lutter contre ce
fléau le projet de loi du gouvernement
prévoit la création de pôles spécialisés
dans les violences intrafamilales il
devrait être mis en place dès janvier
2024 hier en séance Laurence Rossignol
an ministre socialiste de la famille a
dénoncé un manque d'ambition et quelle
déception en tout et pour tout dans ce
texte nous avons un amendement qui crée
les pôles spécialisées vous allez me
dire c'est mieux que rien je vais vous
dire que des pôles spécialisés c'est
sans doute mieux que rien mais les
poules spécialisées c'était pas la
promesse du président de la République
la preuve se présente de la République
c'était des juridictions spécialisées
les pôles spécialisés faute de mieux
nous nous en contenterons et nous
verrons ce qui existe déjà s'étendre et
ce sera une bonne chose mais ce n'est
pas ce que nous voulions aucun doute sur
le fait que les sénateurs seront
vigilants sur un certain nombre
d'articles comme l'article 3 qui fait
polémique puisqu'il prévoit la
possibilité d'activer à distance un
téléphone pour capter des images et des
sons dans le cadre d'enquête terroristes
ou concernant le grand banditisme merci
à tiens votre avis sur ce cet article de
là Stéphane laurier
mon avis c'est attention
l'équilibre entre la sécurité des
personnes et les libertés individuelles
on est dans le respect de la
Constitution donc il faut avoir des ces
mesures sont peut-être peuvent être
efficientes si dorénavant on a des
gardes fous qui nous permettent de
protéger les libertés individuelles de
tout à chacun mais pour en revenir au
texte sur la globalité je pense que
c'est une belle bonne réforme de
l'institution judiciaire mais ce n'est
pas une réforme en profondeur et c'est
ce que disait ma collègue canaillé de la
justice c'est-à-dire qu'on met beaucoup
de moyens
on réorganise l'institution judiciaire
mais rien par exemple sur la révolution
pénale attendue je prends juste
l'exemple cet édit sur la réécriture à
droite constant à droite constante du
code de procédure pénale c'est un débat
qu'on aura sans doute avec avec les
députés nous ce qu'on demandait est-ce
que ce qui était attendu par les avocats
et aussi par les juges les policiers
c'est la réécriture et la simplification
du code de procédure pénale pour aboutir
à 300 300 articles au lieu des 1400
actuels aujourd'hui rien ne nous
garantit que ce travail de réécriture
n'est pas qu'un travail de
recalification alors forcément il sera
plus lisible j'entends bien mais il
faudra je pense ce travail de réforme
sinon on risque de recodifier et après
repartir sur réenclencher une réforme du
Code de Procédure prénatale et puis le
deuxième aspect ce qui manque dans ce
texte c'est la politique pénitentiaire
encore une fois le nombre de places de
prison fait que on est défaillant au
niveau de de la chaîne pénale 15000
places de prison supplémentaires
annoncées
l'engagement du président Macron sur son
premier carnet quinquennat il y en a eu
que 2000 il y a des causes exogènes
quand même qui fait que ils n'ont pas pu
produire les 13000 mais quand même c'est
largement trop alors sur les 15000 il
reste quatre ans pour 15000 places de
prison avec des difficultés qui sont
notables c'est que certains élus locaux
certains meurent des cas de fer pour
faire des LR pardon c'est pas mal de
l'herbe d'ailleurs sur leur
moi j'ai proposé deux solutions hier au
ministre de la justice il faut des
mesures incitatives pour les maires pour
forcer l'implantation c'est-à-dire
revaloriser leur dotation globale de
fonctionnement en prenant en compte la
population carcérale dans le calcul de
la DGS ou encore l'exonération de ce
qu'on appelle la pénalité sur les
logements sociaux que paye certaines
communes lourdement en considérant une
cellule comme un logement on démarre
là-dessus sur la la politique enfin le
nombre de créations de place
est-ce que la loi est à la hauteur des
enjeux alors sur les moyens les moyens
de la loi oui je pense que
tout le monde est d'accord le débat
qu'on peut avoir sur la question de la
reconndification ça je veux bien qu'on
en parle après je vous entendre sur les
prisons d'abord parce que sur les gens
il y a deux aspects il y a la
construction des nouvelles places mais
si on fait que construire des nouvelles
places on y arrivera pas donc il faut
aussi avoir les alternatives à
l'emprisonnement dans ce texte il y a un
volet sur les tiges donc les travaux
d'intérêt généraux qui ont 40 ans
aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui grâce à
l'agence du tige qui a été créé par
cette mandat par la mandature précédente
permet de d'avoir des postes de tiges
pour pour un certain nombre de de gens
de personnes condamnées mais aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on avance par exemple sur les
tiges parce que quand vous avez
quelqu'un en tige c'est quelqu'un qui
potentiellement n'est pas en prison on a
tout un tas de sujets on a des sujets
aussi sur le code la réforme du code de
procédure pénale c'est très délicat
parce que justement suivant les délais
on pourrait avoir un engorgement des
détentions provisoires si on fait pas
attention donc tout ça c'est des sujets
sur lequel il faut travailler en tout
cas une chose est sûre et moi je le
redis à chaque fois les 15000 places de
prison ça prend du temps et ça sera pas
suffisant il faut aussi revoir la
politique pénale et l'application des
peines pour que ça pour que ça coïncide
mais moi j'aimerais bien parler quand
même du code de procédure pénale parce
que il y a allez-y
c'est un sujet important aujourd'hui il
est extrêmement complexe plus personne
ne s'y retrouve et vous avez d'ailleurs
parfois dans nos auditions en ce moment
des gens qui nous disent surtout ne
touchez à rien et puis vous avez ceux
qui disent révolutionner tout donc je
pense que le choix qui a été de fait de
travailler par ordonnance c'est une
bonne un bon principe et on va y arriver
comme on a bien réussi le code de la
Réformation comment étape par étape
c'est ça une ordonnance c'est que on va
avoir deux ans de travail avec un comité
d'ailleurs parlementaire avec un groupe
de liaison et un et un groupe de
scientifiques pour avoir une version qui
va avoir un certain nombre de
simplification il y a des
simplifications il y a des incohérences
qu'il faudra régler et ça ça pourrait
être une loi d'habilitation qui pourra
régler certaines choses et on va avancer
on aura un code pénal qui sera plus
simple plus efficace c'est nécessaire
aujourd'hui c'est une demande de tous
les de tous les magistrats de tous les
avocats et de les greffiers également de
tout le monde il faut être vigilant moi
je suis d'accord on va pas polémiquer
sur habilitation palmitation je pense
que c'est la bonne la bonne méthode
parce que j'imagine très mal
elle parle le Parlement légiférer sur
sur
la masse
notamment des scientifiques de juge et
voire d'université mais là où c'est
déléguer un peu du pouvoir
c'est qu'on est bel et bien le projet de
loi de ratification pour qu'on puisse
mais ça il faut y veiller et pour pas
qu'on soit totalement décisive
effectivement puisque vous sur 21% des
lois qui sont aujourd'hui ratifier donc
il y a vraiment un sujet sur le code de
la justice pénale des mineurs où il y
avait des doutes et on a aujourd'hui un
code de justice pénale de la mine des
mineurs qui marchent bien mieux qui a
réduit considérable considérablement les
délais qui est un succès donc on va
faire la même chose je voudrais juste
revenir sur la population carcérale
parce que quand on parle effectivement
de la peine faut savoir qu'il y a que 59
% de des personnes qui sont condamnées à
la prison ferme qui vont en cellule donc
vous n'êtes pas forcément d'accord pour
booster les les travaux d'intérêt
général c'est à dire que si on le juge
condamne à de la prison ferme je pense
que la société attend de cette personne
qu'elle aille en cellule aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas possible parce qu'on a une
surpopulation carcérale 140% dans les
maisons d'arrêt 118% au niveau des
centres de de détention ce qui veut dire
que il faut déjà rattraper le retard
pour éviter cette surpopulation
carcérale parce que derrière il y a la
dignité de la personne qui est qui est
en prison et ça pas mal de
parlementaires dénonce aussi les
conditions de détention et derrière ça
permet effectivement au juge quand il le
juge nécessaire de prononcer de la
prison ferme parce que aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que parfois les
aménagements de peine sont là en fait
pour des engorger le milieu carcéral je
voudrais vous entendre aussi sur la
possibilité de tenir les promesses quand
on est 1800 greffiers est-ce que est-ce
qu'on est en 1500 dans le texte 1500
mais vous avez le monde en 1800 est-ce
qu'on est en capacité de les recruter
tout simplement tout à l'heure on était
formé déjà on était en audition avec les
l'École nationale de la magistrature
alors elle forme pas les greffiers elles
forment les les magistrats eux ils se
sont mis en ordre de marche et
d'ailleurs le chiffre 2500 correspond
aussi à une réalité de de moyens qui
peuvent avoir et qui ont supplémentaires
qui ont été mis et sur les greffiers il
va falloir faire exactement la même
chose et oui si on s'est engagé sur les
1500 et 1500 c'est que justement il y a
une projection et des études faites pour
pour y aller on va c'est massif
imaginez qu'aujourd'hui depuis la
naissance de l'École nationale de la
magistrature il y a eu 11000 magistrats
formés et on va en former 1500
supplémentaires 1500 net c'est pas 1500
avec ses 1500 net en 2027 donc c'est un
effort considérable ça demande une
organisation il y a des bâtiments
nouveaux qui sont en train d'être
construits à Bordeaux assez grand
aujourd'hui voilà et une belle école et
elle va être efficace et à côté de ça il
y a aussi les filières de recrutement
des magistrats qui vont être vus parce
que l'idée c'est aussi de de changer les
profils pour qu'il n'y ait pas que des
étudiants et qui est aussi des gens qui
arrivent avec un parcours professionnel
donc c'est un beau projet en réalité
c'est un beau projet qu'on a de société
de reconnexion de notre société avec le
monde de la justice
un effort de rattrapage disons-le
clairement en 2018 la Commission
européenne avait pointé notamment la
France où on les 69 euros par habitant
pour notre justice pendant que
l'Allemagne donnait 132 euros et ça fait
des décennies je n'accade
qu'on oublie tout le temps c'est que la
France a une justice par les prud'hommes
oui une justice par l'effet c'est pour
ça que la comparaison avec l'Allemagne
est surtout un autre point la justice
administrative qui traite un certain
nombre de sujets que qui sont en
Allemagne traités par la justice
dans le budget vraiment 40% sur
l'ensemble du rattrapage on est d'accord
j'ai pas trop de doutes sur les
recrutements en revanche attention il
faut véritablement que le Parlement se
saisisse de cette révolution pénale qui
manque cruellement dans le texte
conclusion 30 secondes
ce budget en forte hausse c'est une
réalité tout le monde le voilà le
message au crédit du des règles
Dupond-Moretti et les Français est-ce
que sa personnalité écrase pas un peu
son bilan qu'est-ce que vous diriez de
ça c'est sûr que c'est un vrai problème
c'est à dire qu'effectivement si son
image etc n'était pas si présente
peut-être qu'on parlerait plus de son
bilan mais il me semble quand même que
aujourd'hui j'ai regardé je me suis dit
comment comment mes confrères moi-même
enfin mon journal c'est ça comment on
parle de tout ça j'avoue je fais un
petit mais à coulent pas qu'on en parle
pas beaucoup
toute seule voilà merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappellerai rapidement le titre de votre
livre la tyrannie de la médiocrité
Sophie Coignières qui est publié aux
éditions de l'Observatoire à demain pour
un nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
notez que dans la matinale l'invité
Dorian Mancini c'est Laurent Marc Angeli
le président du groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée belle soirée